I think this is my favorite comment.
Why would a woman sacrifice her heart,
her energy, her time,
her effort,
her years to find a mate on somebody who is willingly broken?
Why does she have to sacrifice herself?
Why do we always have to play this martyr
in order to be considered worthy?
Why do we need to pay the price for their deficiencies
and then be called not a good woman
because you didn't stay to take the abuse.
And abuse is a strong word,
so let's call it take. The lack of care,
the lack of emotional investment.
As a very happily married woman to a very confident,
well loving man, I have to tell you,
a man who truly cherishes your heart will not treat it so carelessly.
And a man who is capable of a long term commitment
isn't going to have to be taught.
The labor and emotional sacrifice in that is beyond.
Do not commit to a woman
until you are capable of what is required of a long term commitment.
That's it. Most women just want a partner, not a project.